on the surface the relegation battle
doesn't look all that tense in nuremberg
current second to last kickoff sent
reporter constantine stuva down to
southern germany to check on the club's
battle against the drop
and who better to talk to than 35 year
old goalkeeper rafael schaefer
nuremberg's captain
he's experienced with more than 300
bundesliga matches under his belt
he's also known for his emotional
occasionally even belligerent style
but as we found out off the pitch
schaefer is a perfectly amiable fellow
he may be a fierce competitor but he's
kept his sense of perspective
so how are you sleeping these days
yeah then he should think twice about
that because i don't think it'll get him
anywhere it'll just cost him a lot of
mental and physical strength
if he broods too much
there are situations you have to deal
with very intensively but you still have
to unwind now and then
otherwise it'll take too much energy and
it'll eat you alive you need that energy
on the pitch
how is the relegation battle affecting
you
every year i've been in nuremberg at
some point i hear someone saying
relegation battle
it's just part of the game
in both the positive and negative sense
lots of outbursts in both directions now
guess which keeper in the bundesliga has
the most yellow cards right now
not me
me really
i only have three
well they weren't justified i think one
was because of a penalty i caused
club
and there was an unjustified card
but the other one was justified okay
but you've collected quite a few in your
career
i've had worse
four yellow cards after just 17 match
days once and i had to make sure i
didn't get any more before the end of
season playoff
so i'm still pretty relaxed
what does that say about you
well that's just the way it is
when you're a team captain sometimes you
have to see and do things that aren't
very nice
and you have to defend your team a bit
more vigorously
as a keeper you're condemned to the role
of spectator in certain situations
aren't you
yeah but that comes with being a keeper
i'm not unhappy with my situation
i became a keeper because i wanted to
i know what my role is and what
strengths will help the team
that's all i can do a keeper rarely wins
a match the best of keeper can do is
keep his team in the game
what does nuremberg have to do to stay
in the running win
what does nuremberg have to do to win
maybe we have to try at the decisive
moments to play with efficiency
aggressiveness and drive
we absolutely have to win two matches
and if we do i'm certain we'll end up in
the end of season playoffs
we'll do what we have to do to stay in
the league
and i don't care if braunschweig hamburg
stuttgart or some other team ends up
behind us
but it's important for us to do our
homework and to win our matches and then
we won't have to depend on some team
losing and us winning in the final round
i think it's important for us to work
everything out in advance so we can take
action
do you have any kind of sympathy for
your competitors
nobody has any sympathy for us why
should they this is a sport not a
chronic disease if it were a disease i
could sympathize
but this is a matter of leaving two or
if all goes well three teams behind you
that's the objective
it's a sporting endeavor not one that
affects health or lifestyle
except for the way it affects the fans
but that's something else
this is a sport
a competition
you